i go into my knife tomorrow i had to go
get swabbed oh daddy's getting
oh crap it's done tomorrow daddy gets
his lids done
we should document 6 30 a.m oh now i
know
too early why is that early well that's
how they do it in beverly hills only
time they can fit papa in well and papa
goes in at 6 30 i'll probably
the surgeon will probably get there at
at
jason dr jason diamond he'll do it at
you know probably
uh eight is he working on the con it was
so funny
yeah i looked through my go uh no no
cocaine
no blow i know no whiskey like the night
before if you don't mind because you're
gonna he goes
i'll get to bed by four i promise i'll
get a bid by 4am don't worry about it
and now is there
any chance that they could have a hiccup
and you look like a sniper for the rest
of your life i said to him i said
now listen i can't have you [ __ ] this
up he goes
there's not a chance don't worry about
it i go yeah but i read on the
like who was i was so what about droopy
eyelashes oh you've been on youtube
yeah well don't do that don't youtube
your operation what exactly are they
doing papa they're gonna take they make
an incision take an injure
off the floor they take this well
you're gonna take the nuts off the top
take these lids see when i squeeze them
yeah take those nuts and then they're
going to go oh
they're going to go lower bottoms
they're going to go lower and they're
going to take a little here off here
apparently he said i would do it you're
getting behind surgery and then
they shoot a little fat in the eyelids
from from my little tummy
i guess they're taking how they get the
fat out they they do a
liposuction and i guess they spin skin
like you're getting lipo well tiny bits
under my eyes look i don't like any of
this
i don't have a tummy bro god damn it
are you going under for this person i
gotta go under oh oh i don't like that
that's why you can't drink
anything for 12 months from time i can't
believe you have to go under
dude why don't you take some skin off
your dick i could have them do that i
could
why don't you have them cinch up your
nuts cinch my nuts it's down to you
guys yeah i got some issues um damn you
have to go under there's nothing scary
yeah it's not scary i've done it before
johnny west mom died
yeah get elective surgery well i did it
i did it for
a colonoscopy they stick a camera up
your [ __ ]
and then i did it for my double hernia
but like i don't know how long ago
yeah going on there's so scary but you
can't believe you have to go under to do
that though
um do you know my stomach was never the
same after double hernia surgery
my i i was like i had that pouch like it
bloats out a little bit yeah that's what
i have from
[ __ ] from my surgery how many
surgeries how many times you've been
under
just one nose and broken hand broken
nose broken hand
[ __ ] it's though it's so well when they
pack you when they unpack it so scary
but i'm just saying when you're going in
there and like right count to ten it's
like cold
you're basically
the smallest it's ever going to be right
now because you're about to go under the
knife it's cold
and your dick goes retreat i know and by
the way i think about that i think about
the nurses looking at my
my my dog yep but luckily this is my
eyes so they shouldn't be looking at my
dick
although you shouldn't be naked oh you
gotta get your tummy
i got myself while they're gonna talk to
them about while they're in there just
do the thing
what's that just like suck all the fat
right well
no not that there's that much but you
might as well if you're in there yeah
i don't even get my lids done but i
could use a little lipo
careful you go down this this road i
mean now i see [ __ ]
now i had a i had a doctor hit me up
and shows me what they can do with
people before and after and it will
blow your mind it blows your phone i
could come here looking like a giant
mario lopez
they do they can do anything with no
workout can eat whatever the [ __ ] i want
and jason diamond is recognized by the
other people in the field as the
most renowned facial surgeon he doesn't
just do plastics
for bodies you go and take go on down to
tj there's a guy down there that a lot
of celebs go to you stay there you're
there a week
recovery times about seven days and
they'll take your
your stupid frumpy body and turn you
into [ __ ] mister
because uh our boys girl did her ass her
brazilian butt lift in miami
miami yeah and then she got it done he
paid for it that's a major operation my
buddy paid for it she likes to redick
and she went
see ya savage she she's now she only
does anal
well congratulations on that she you
have to massage your butt
okay you have to get massages for like
six weeks it's crazy uh okay i'll do it
i know i mean i'll be the massager let
me help you out she's just
massage the fat into the and he paid for
it but pretty soon you're going to be
able to use stem cells and grow
your own tissue where you need it that's
going to be awesome
you're going to be able to grow sciences
sciencing it going so much every dude if
he wants to be shredded it's going to be
able to be shredded
you can i'm telling you you can do this
procedure now and get shredded and the
fat never they
burn it so fat can't grow what do you
mean they sent me a whole pamphlet on
like
i'm just not that what do you mean just
not get that kind of
so you can get you can get shredded i'll
i'll i'm
i don't want to out the thing i'll send
you the stuff they sent me like oh
jesus christ wow it's nuts what the [ __ ]
nuts i would imagine you could also take
winstrol etc and just get shredded
but but you have to be on straw and do
like eat clean to get shred this
they burn it and can't grow back there
and they they can actually sculpt the
abs
[ __ ] and no thank you and they they have
over a hundred people like they show
before and after you're like
holy [ __ ] it's so tempting bring that
[ __ ] but it'd be
yeah well the problem is is like i'm not
so
superficial where i do it and also can
you imagine if i died that way
and then tiger embossed and like how'd
your dad did you know he was trying to
comic
he was yeah i know he was talking about
his body he was a good guy
he was a great guy he was tummy always
bothered him he left you guys to become
more shredded
because at the end of the day his vanity
was more important than both of you
so carry that with you the rest of your
life and if you need me
i'm going to be busy but i'll be around
for a phone call
probably pretty busy pretty busy because
you don't know what happened to kanye
west's mom
so she wanted everything done face
stomach lipo she wanted like
titties ass she wanted everything done
at once and she went to several doctors
and then i'm sure she went to diamond
all of them went nope too many you're
under the knife too long sure
there's so many complications well
finally she found one no
some guy went i'll do it connie wentz
mom i'll do it
against all protocol did it when she
passed away oh he she's down for too
long
he did oh he did but still it doesn't
matter can't bring the mom back
she got done lipo face tits i never woke
up
never woke up and you got to be careful
look good in the casket though
yep and there it is um
what would you do what would you have
done only your ears
no i won't touch my ears no i'll have
this guy they
got they take whatever fat you have you
have a very full
sculpt you have a full mouth you
absolutely need something absolutely
no women pay a lot of money for these
lips they pay a lot of money for those
lips you got tits
and you got a full mouth you got a dick
on me too
[Music]
how the [ __ ] i'm gonna look jesus oh
[ __ ] did he did
did that not he probably didn't
specialize him i'm not even trying to be
funny at all did he say anything about
your hair though like did he say
what do you say when you're under you
know you could give you a full right his
partner is the best hair transplant
guy in the business you have no desire i
would but i mean
if you do one thing at a time and also
it doesn't matter to me it's not going
to make a difference
let's be honest bro you were the problem
is if you start doing this you become an
old guy who's getting work done
or are you the old guy with great hair i
don't believe that
my hair is salvageable i don't believe
well no that no
we're gonna get shave that we're gonna
we're gonna scalp you and we put some
new products
oh that when i can when they can clone
hair daddy will have your hair believe
me i will walk in
with a full head of hair and new eyes
i'll be great but until then
i'm not doing this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been
she was doing disrespected